hey hey hey oh Steve hi it was so nice
oh rally
okay so today as you can see we have Jen
Klein in the room with us in the
briefing room director of the gender
policy Council here to discuss today's
event uh marking the 30th anniversary of
the family and medical leave act as well
as how the administration is fighting
for women and their Access to Health
Care amid extreme attacks from
Republican officials just across the
country so she has a a hard a hard time
out right you have to get it get out of
here because she does have to meet with
the president in the Oval Office in a
few minutes but she wanted to speak with
all of you and take some questions and
check holding you or something
I'll take that question
um good morning later today President
Biden is hosting an event in honor of
the 30th anniversary of the Family and
Medical Leave Act he will be joined by
vice president Harris and several
members of his cabinet and will welcome
President Bill Clinton back to the White
House to celebrate the first bill that
President Clinton signed in office
the Family and Medical Leave Act came
about after years of work by Advocates
and members of Congress including
support by President Biden as a senator
and from an historic number of women
Trailblazers in Congress some of whom
will join the president at the White
House today this event is a moment to
recognize the difference that the Family
and Medical Leave Act has made and
continues to make for millions of
Americans but it's also a moment to
recognize the work that remains to be
done to support workers including the
need to pass a national Paid Family and
Medical Leave law the president will
discuss recent actions the
Administration has taken to support
women in the workplace including through
the year-end Omnibus which included the
passage of the pregnant workers Fairness
Act and the pump for nursing mothers act
as well as significant investments in
child care to give you an idea of what
these wins mean for women the pregnant
workers Fairness Act requires employers
to offer reasonable accommodations to
pregnant women and new moms basic long
overdue protections like bathroom breaks
and a stool to sit on this is good for
maternal Health infant health and it's
also good for the economic security of
women and their families ensuring that
they're not pushed out of a job and
instead can stay in the workforce and
continue supporting their families it
also allows workers to take time off
from to recover from childbirth
including many women who don't have
access to parental leave
the president is also committed to
continuing to support women's Economic
Security which is why today he issued a
presidential memorandum to support
federal employees access to leave when
they need to care for themselves or
loved one including during their first
year of employment and for reasons
related to domestic violence Dating
Violence sexual assault or stalking
fighting for women's Economic Security
is the top priority of course but I
would also like to touch on another
priority protecting access to
reproductive care for women across the
country amid a wave of extreme
legislation at the state and National
level as a result of the Supreme Court's
decision in Dobbs versus Jackson Women's
Health Organization more than 26 million
women in the United States currently
live in a state that has banned abortion
and while the president and the vice
president stand with the majority of
Americans in believing that the right to
choose is fundamental we continue to
face an all-out assault by Republican
officials on women's access to
reproductive care I'll just outline
briefly the focus of our fight right now
first we're fighting anti-choice
legislation in Congress since House
Republicans took office they have
proposed three separate National
Abortion bans and an additional number
of bills to restrict access to
reproductive care the president and the
Senate Democrats will be a firewall
against this extreme legislation while
continuing to call on Congress to
restore the protections of Roe versus
Wade as federal law that lead me to our
second Focus which is taking executive
action to defend Reproductive Rights as
you know the president has already
issued two executive orders to safeguard
access to reproductive health care and
on what would have been the 50th
anniversary of Roe the president took
another step issuing a presidential
memorandum to further support safe
access to medication abortion these
efforts are extremely critical and
especially critical in the face of
Republican officials denying the science
threatening pharmacies and fighting
access to Safe FDA approved medication
and I'll remind you that medication
abortion accounts for more than half of
all abortions in the United States
we're also working closely with State
leaders who are fighting to defend
Reproductive Rights those on the front
lines of addressing the more than 100
anti-choice bills that have already been
filed for the 2023 legislative session
and we're we're supporting State leaders
and taking proactive action again to as
well to protect access to abortion this
week Minnesota Governor Tim Walls signed
the pro act making Minnesota the first
state in 2023 to pass legislation
codifying the protections of Roe so
there's a lot of work to be done to
ensure women everywhere in this country
are treated with the dignity and respect
they deserve but the president remains
committed to fighting for gender
equality and gender equity and I really
look forward to taking your questions
there's a white jacket
hi Jen I'm Courtney Rose I'm from
Florida government I wanted to ask you
you were talking about
um abortion medication there's a
conservative group in Texas with seeking
an injunction to stop Mr Christian
distribution the group is called
Alliance for defending Freedom what will
you do or the White House do to help
counter the suit I know that this
touches on what you're trying to do to
expand access to abortion drugs and will
you more clearly argue that the fda's
regulations on the abortion pill crayon
state law
thanks Courtney um I'm not going to
comment on pending litigation and of
course I direct you to the Department of
Justice to um to talk more about that
but I do want to step back and look at
the facts um mifoprestone has been on
the market for 20 years the FDA
determined that it is safe and effective
and it's used all around the world and
as I just said it accounts for the
majority of abortions here in the United
States lawsuits and Other Extreme
Measures that have been announced by
state officials including threats to the
litigation you just referred to threats
to pharmacies are about coming after the
the right to access care and FDA
approved medication and that's why we
are going to remain committed to
protecting legal access to medication
abortion within the limits of the law
and that's why the president has already
taken several steps to to do that and
reaffirm this in his most recent um
in his most recent presidential
memorandum on medication abortion
important state level leaders and
specific about what that means how
you're supporting them
um we've met regularly and and the vice
president has met with hundreds of state
legislators over the course of the um
last months really since the Dobbs
decision came down to help them bring
them together so that they can share
information about both how to pass
proactive State legislation to protect
Reproductive Rights and also to fight
back defensively against the extreme
legislation that they're seeing in
States and so you've already seen a
number of states pass helpful
legislation and you know as I just
mentioned the fight goes on because
there are a hundred bills already
filed in the 2023 legislative session
that are anti-choice and so we will
continue to work with state legislators
Governors Mayors
um uh to to and State Attorneys General
to help them in that fight
thank you thank you for being here today
um really quickly there are Democrats
that are calling on the presidents who
have paying the proposal and the
upcoming budget can you um kind of talk
about that I can talk about what's in
the president's budget um but what I can
note is that he include a Paid Family
and Medical Leave proposal in both his
FY 22 and FY 23 budgets and he has been
quite clear
um and and talked about this in the
campaign and and prior to that about his
support for Paid Family and Medical
Leave
thank you um as you just noted the
president has pushed for this before
other administrations have been through
this before why do you think now is
different now is the time to renew this
push especially when you've seen this
fall fallen short before well I think
you know we've seen and I I just noted a
few
um really pretty major legislative wins
with bipartisan support the pregnant
workers Fairness Act it's been
introduced for 10 years and finally
passed with as I said strong bipartisan
support and I think that you know the
lesson there is that you keep fighting
for the things that are good for
families Working Families and by the way
good for the economy which is very much
true of Paid Family Leave in the
president's entire care agenda which
also includes of course child care and
Elder Care
yeah are you satisfied I'm wondering
with the Supreme Court's uh
investigation that concluded over the
leaking of the dog's decision you know
there's been some criticism that Michael
chertoff advised it and then also that
the justices themselves weren't under
oath and got to sort of beat by the
process
I could take that once you're done okay
yeah I'll come back to that
anything anybody else
um Jen I wondered has you have you seen
any movement from one moderate
Republicans on Reproductive Rights
um you know you were mentioning that
there's been bipartisan support for some
of these other
um pieces of legislation when it comes
to families I just wonder on the issue
of Reproductive Rights like where where
are you guys with trying to move more
moderate Republicans well um the
president has been really clear that the
only way to replace a
fundamental constitutional rate that has
been Pat that has been taken away which
is what the Supreme Court did in the
dabs decision is to pass Federal
legislation codifying the protections
that existed under Roe and he will and
we will and the vice president will
continue to work to do that with anybody
who is willing to work with us on that I
will note that you know we have heard
and seen um you know quite publicly some
Republicans trying to moderate their
view but I think it's really important
to look at their voting record many who
are talking about protecting women's
Access to Health Care are actually
voting quite differently they voted for
bills that ban or severely restrict
abortion they've actually co-sponsored
legislation to to ban abortion and you
know this summer a number of them did
not vote for the right to contraception
act which would both protect and expand
the right to contraception
the last question in the back
I was just wondering the HHS secretary
brought up the prospect of an emergency
on abortion again earlier this week he
sort of said that an evaluation was
still underway do you have any
um Insight of that from the White
House's perspective yes I mean we have
said before
um and I will continue to say that no
option is is off the table that will
expand access to reproductive health
care but at this point we don't believe
that declaring a public health emergency
would provide meaningful new resources
in this fight
appreciate it thank you thank you for
your time thank you all right I just
have a couple things at the top
and then we'll get to it
um okay so as you know last week
President Biden told Tyree Nichols
family that he would continue pushing
Congress to send the joy Floyd Justice
in policing act to his desk to that end
the president will host some members of
Congressional Black Caucus at the White
House later today to discuss shared
priorities including the path forward to
police reform in Congress and the vice
president will also be in attendance
this is an issue that is deeply
important to the president and one that
he has long partnered with members of of
the Congressional Black Caucus on
members of the Congressional Black
Caucus were critical Partners in
advancing the George Floyd Justice and
policing act last session and when
Senate Republicans blocked the
legislation from reaching the
president's desk the President worked
with members of the Congressional Black
Caucus to take sweeping executive action
to set the gold standard for Effective
accountable policing at the federal
level today's Oval Office meeting will
provide an opportunity to discuss the
important reforms that have already been
implemented because the president acted
when Congress could not or would not
reforms like Banning Chokehold
significantly restricting no knock
warrants and requiring the use of body
cams at the federal level and immediate
changes like prohibiting the transfer of
military grade Firearms Granite grenade
launchers and other military equipment
to law enforcement agencies but as the
president has repeatedly said no
executive action can substitute Federal
legislation real and Lasting change at
the state and local levels will require
Congress to act it will require
republicans in Congress to stop getting
in the way of ensuring our justice
system lives up to its name the
president will continue to do everything
in his power to fight for police reform
in Congress and he looks forward to
meeting with members of the
Congressional Black Caucus today on the
path forward
today as well we're also marking the one
year anniversary of the president and
the first ladies reigniting the cancer
moonshot with the ambitious goal of
cutting cancer deaths in half over the
next 25 years and improving the
experience of Americans living with and
surviving cancer
in the past year the cancer moonshot has
announced over 25 new programs policies
and resources to help close the
screening Gap support patients and
caregivers Advanced Cutting Edge
research and so much more
and today the moonshot announced new
actions that will build on the strong
Foundation including a first of its kind
program to connect kids fighting cancer
and their families with the patient the
patient navigation support they need
this is this issue is deeply personal
for so many Americans including the
president and the first lady the first
lady has been a tireless champion of the
cancer moonshot traveling the country
and the world to hear from cancer
patients and their families as well as
those who support them focusing on the
importance of early detection and
improving the experience of patients
families and caregivers in fact she'll
be in San Diego tomorrow to visit a
community health center that's receiving
moonshot funding to increase cancer
screenings and underserved communities
thanks to the work of the moonshot the
federal government has never been more
committed to ending cancer as we know it
finally I wanted to say a few words
about an incredible colleague that I
have had the pleasure of working with
who will soon be leaving the white house
for over two years Brian deese has
served as the Director of the National
Economic Council and as one of the
president's most trusted advisors Brian
has helped shape and pass the most
significant economic agenda in
Generations the American Rescue plan
which brought our economy back from the
brink the bipartisan infrastructure law
the most most significant investment in
our nation's infrastructure in
Generations the chips and science act
which ensures we make more high-end
technology here at home so we can
out-compete the world
and the inflation reduction act which is
giving millions of families a little bit
of a breathing room investing in clean
energy manufacturing and addressing the
climate crisis Brian has helped steer
the president's economic Vision into
reality by helping families get back to
work businesses reopen and bring prices
under control
he has been an effective leader in
President Biden's efforts to rebuild our
economy so no one is Left Behind part of
Brian's success has been the incredible
team that he built at NEC his strong
team is the most diverse NEC in history
60 percent women and 50 percent people
of color
he has he has a way of translating very
complex economic information as you all
know he's been in this briefing room
many times in front of all of you taking
your questions and he has been able to
translate that into language all of us
can understand
one of what and I would say
we will miss Brian very much we miss his
kindness his intelligence and just again
uh just being a an amazing colleague but
I know how excited his family is to have
more of his time and we wish Brian the
absolute the absolute best in his next
chapter with that Colleen
thank you
um on the Philippines
I wondered if you had confirmation on
what islands the bases would be
stationed on and then I'm sorry no no go
ahead I'm so sorry you should finish a
question um and then is there a concern
that the expanded military presence
could
further provoke China so on the
specifics of where of the location I
would refer you to the Department of
Defense refer you to my colleagues there
and look the way that I would see this
is as a very important Alliance and a
partnership with the Philippines as you
ask about China but that's the way that
we perceive this and how we're moving
forward as a important partnership and
again an alliance that we have with the
Philippines and then on the meeting with
McCarthy yesterday I wondered if you
could elaborate a little bit on what
continuing the conversation looks like
and he specifically had mentioned to
reporters
um outside that there was a follow-up
call scheduled at the White House I
wondered if that was happening or had
happened so as you heard from the
speaker and also from the president it
was a good discussion it was an honest
discussion our senior staff has followed
up and communicated our appreciation to
the speaker's team and we will continue
to stay in touch as we have been for the
past several months I don't have any
calls to preview or to speak to but
again I mean you heard directly from uh
from the speakers I believe he spoke for
about 30 minutes at the stakes yesterday
taking your questions as well and he
said it was productive and again it was
as I said a very good discussion and we
appreciated his time
come here on that same topic there was a
fair amount of optimism on both sides
coming out of that meeting yesterday but
the speaker has now said to reporters
again that there will be no clean debt
ceiling hike so why the cause for
optimism
well look
the cause for optimism is because you
heard it from the speaker himself it was
a good discussion it was going to be a
continuing conversation that they're
going to have and there are real uh real
discussions to continue as it relates to
the uh to uh to the American people when
you look at the deficit more broadly and
how we we need to lower continue to
lower the deficit and what the president
has done the last two years you've heard
me talk about that many times from the
podium and we have said we have said
very loud and clear to the speaker if he
has any ideas on how to work together on
that we're willing to listen and work in
good faith but look as it relates as
I've always said when it comes to
lifting the debt ceiling that is a
completely separate issue and that has
not changed you saw that from our
readout yesterday you've heard this from
me you heard it from the president
you've heard it from Brian deese and
others in this Administration that that
we need to do that without conditions
the debt ceiling needs to be lifted
without conditions and uh and so we
still stand by that that has not changed
we believe we truly believe it is a
constitutional duty of Congress
Republican Democrats Independents to get
that done as we have seen this done 78
times before since 1960. given the
optimism I understand you don't you're
not going to detail negotiations because
this is an ongoing process but should we
take that there were potential areas of
agreement that were identified here I
wouldn't I look I'm not going to speak
for the speaker I'm certainly am not his
spokesperson but President Biden has
made it very clear that it is up to
Congress to live out their Congressional
Duty and to avoid a economic catastrophe
as it relates to a default like we've
been very clear on that and he even said
uh the speaker as you just mentioned
Mary I think you were alluding to this
we're not going to negotiate in public
on anything that is related right to
fiscal
responsibility and what it is that they
they want to move forward with the house
the House Republicans what it is what it
is what is it their plan is going to be
with the president and has said he's
been clear on the on the the debt
ceiling we're not where it should be
done without conditions uh he's willing
and ready to discuss how we can lower
costs when it comes to the deficit and
he has said as well he's going to have
his budget uh and show what he believes
is his fiscal priorities are uh we'll
show how uh we need to be fiscally
responsible as we talk about the
American people he'll have that on March
9th and he asked the speaker to do the
same and just one more the state of the
union is coming up I was wondering if
you could give us a sense of how the
president is preparing for this where he
may be in the speech writing process
who's helping him with that it's a it's
a good question as you know the
president has been working on on the on
his speech for some time he sees this as
an opportunity and I suppose I've spoken
to this before not just to address the
Congress and the members of Congress
clearly but also as an opportunity to
speak directly to the American people
he's done it at least twice before this
will be his third time and uh so he
takes this very seriously these types of
speeches continue to evolve sometimes
until the final moments before being
delivered as you can imagine and but you
can expect the president to hit on many
of the issues that you hear him speak
about every day the significant economic
progress we're seeing under his
leadership his economic Vision that's
building our economy from the bottom up
and middle out the historic pieces of
legislation pass into law over the last
two years which are creating good paying
middle class jobs and delivering Real
Results for people by fixing our roads
Bridges tunnels lowering costs on
everyday Goods those are just a few
examples that you will hear from the
president I will also say somebody just
asked I don't know mayor venue Mary
about the optimism that that you see
from this President right this is
something that you have heard from him
over and over again especially in the
last two years is how he is optimistic
about the future of this country and
you'll hear some of that as well and the
possibilities I've said this before you
hear that from the president as well the
possibilities that we have as a country
especially as we look get our economy as
we look at things moving forward the
speaker mentioned that the debate could
go on for five months is that what
you're expecting as well is that okay
with you look what we
what we what we have been very clear
about
um and I'll say it again when it comes
to the debt ceiling it is something that
should be done it is something that is
is a constitutional duty of uh of uh
house house of the of Congress more
broadly and look look we're not talking
about new spending we're talking about
spending that the Congress has racked up
over the last couple of years you know
if you think about where uh the debt is
currently 90 of that debt happened
before the president even walked into
office so it is a it is uh it is
something that they should get done and
they voted on this when it comes to
lifting the debt ceilings three times in
the last Administration so we don't see
any negotiation here we don't see
anything that needs to be discussed we
see this as a duty that they have to get
this done again when it comes to
lowering the deficit when it comes to
actually coming up with real policies to
do that and you've seen the president do
that the last two years 1.7 trillion
dollars in lowering the deficit and you
see that even with the inflation
reduction act which is going to lower
the deficit by 200 billion dollars so
this is something that the president
takes very seriously and those are the
conversations that's the conversation
that he's willing to have and he wants
to see what their plan plan is going to
look like separately secretary blanket
is leaving soon for talk to China is he
going to meet with President XI and what
is the president bides and hoping to get
out of this I believe the state
department has yet to announce any
travel certainly I'm not going to get
ahead of the state department from here
so I I would refer you to them
um on police reform presence obviously
hosting that meeting with members of the
CDC today he said that Justice is long
overdue uh relating to the death of
Tyree Nichols looking at the State of
the Union how much of an emphasis Will
President Biden be placing on police
reforms specifically in that speech and
what kind of request no it's a good
question I'm sure I'm not going to get
ahead of the the president's speech I
want to be very careful on doing that as
I just mentioned it's constantly being
reworked and it will be till the uh to
the very last moment uh but as I said
from the top it is a deeply important
issue for this president again when
Congress could not act or would not act
because Republicans got in the way of
getting a really important critical
piece of legislation to George Floyd
Justice and policing act he stepped in
and what he put forward in the executive
actions clearly on the federal level
dealing with federal agencies was
something that had never been done by
any other president so that shows his
commitment and him today he sitting down
and having a conversation with the
Congressional Black Caucus and
continuing
efforts on how we deal with this issue
how we really truly get to a
transformational change with police
reform I think also shows his commitment
and so that's going to occur later today
as you all know there'll be a pool spray
at the top and you guys will experience
the the President coming together with
the Congressional Black Caucus members
of the Congressional Black Caucus to
have that conversation but certainly I'm
not going to get ahead of what What will
What specifics will be in the president
again I'm not going to get ahead of the
president on what he's going to
specifically talk about I laid out the
economic his economic uh you know what
he's what he has laid out for his
economic policy in the last two years
and he will certainly talk about that I
talked about the optimism that he has
for this country I'm just not going to
go into details about any specific
pieces of legislation that he'll discuss
or issues that he'll discuss Ukraine
officials in recent days have been
warning about this increase in offensive
that they're expecting from Russia one
official saying that that Russia is
preparing for quote maximum escalation
is that an assessment that the White
House shares and is there any plans or
how soon might we see more security
assistance so look as it relates to
security assistance as you know we have
been we have been very consistent in
providing the assistance that the people
of Ukraine need to defend uh the
aggression that they're seeing from
Russia which is almost almost to a year
of that and the president has shown his
commitment throughout this year he's
shown his commitment as you've seen when
President zielinski was here most
recently and many times before in
bringing together NATO bringing together
the West to really have that strong
partnership with our partners and allies
to really help Ukraine in every way that
we can look we're seeing what's
happening you all are reporting on it
very agelessly in what's happening in
Ukraine and we are going to continue to
help Ukraine in any way that we can they
are assessing what's going on in the
battlefields clearly and we are talking
to them on a regular basis to see what
else that we can do to help as far as
security assistance I don't have
anything further to read out and again
we are going to stand by the Ukrainian
people for as long as it takes
thank you
um following up on the police executive
order one part of that was building a
law enforcement accountability database
240 days after the signing of that
executive order we're past that deadline
now
um what's the status of that database it
was cited Often by the administration as
an example of its reform efforts so uh
would have to go back to the team to get
you a number to see exactly where we are
with that database don't have that
number in front of you in front of me
it's pardon me but look I do want to say
that in putting together that executive
order the president and his team worked
with and spoke with had months and
months of Engagement with many folks in
the communities when you think about
civil rights organization you think
about the families who had lost an
individual a loved one to the hands of
police and also law enforcement also
came in and gave us advice and thoughts
on what should be put in the executive
order and if you go back zolan I'm sure
you have you'll see
quotes from many of those different
groups who said how important this
executive order was to move things
forward remember this is a record
historic peace executive order that we
have not seen from any other president
before but I could go back and talk to
the team is it that we don't know how
far we are in terms or is it not yet
what I what I'm saying to you is I just
have to go back to the team to answer
this in a way that answers any questions
that you may have on the database I just
I don't have that information in front
of me uh I'm wondering also just in
terms of the meeting with speaker
speaker McCarthy as well
um he said that they are not touching
Medicare or Social Security did he
clarify what programs he would like to
see spending cuts so look
they need to put forward a plan and we
have not seen a plan yet what we have
seen and heard and you all again have
reported on this I've gone through this
many times before from here is what his
house Republican conference has been
saying that they want to cut Medicare
that they want to cut Social Security
they've been very clear on that we've
seen stories after stories and and we've
heard directly from many members of the
house uh conference Republican
conference to be more specific there and
so that's what we've heard I know that
uh speaker Pelosi has said that on TV
most recently but again what we are
asking for is what's their plan what is
their plan that they're going to perform
the president's going to put forward his
uh his fiscal plan his Budget on March
9th that's going to lay out for the
American people how he sees the fiscal
year 2024 and how he sees delivering for
the American people so let's we want to
see what they are going to put forward
um do you have any idea if the president
signed out for waiting at all on the
release of the Guantanamo Bay detainee
Majid Khan and should we be anticipating
the release of any others so
um on that piece I can let you know and
confirm that uh that today we
transferred uh Mr Khan to Belize after
he finished serving his sentence at
Guantanamo Bay Detention Facility uh
Khan had entered a plea agreement in
2012 in which he pledged to cooperate
with the US government and since that
time he has honored his cooperation uh
commitment I can say more broadly as it
relates to the Guantanamo Bay and the
president's position on that it remains
dedicated we remain dedicated to a
deliberate and thorough process focused
on responsibly reducing the detainee
population at Guantanamo Bay and
ultimately closing the facility that is
still where we stand the Department of
State is seeking to identify suitable
onward transfer countries and negotiate
transfer Arrangements including
appropriate security and Humane
treatment assurances for the remaining
eligible detainees I don't have I know
there's been reports on more detainees
being transported just don't have
anything to share there
um this weekend the Democratic National
Committee is voting to approve a new
calendar for the 2024 primaries and
caucuses it's going to put South
Carolina First followed if they have
their way when Nevada New Hampshire
going second Georgia Michigan after that
I know you cannot specifically discuss
politics because of the hatch activities
that's what you thought tell us but I'm
curious if the president himself
will ever speak publicly about his calls
and the letter he sent to the DNC saying
this should happen I I will say this uh
it's not what I say it's the rule of law
and I I just want to be clear I don't
you kind of just threw it out there as
if it's a personal decision here it is
the rule of law and we believe the rule
of law here we follow it
um you know I have not had that
conversation with the president gonna be
you know very honest with you I've not
talked to him about 2024 is that
something that we can do from here and
I'm sure you will hear a lot more uh
from the president uh uh you know moving
forward but I just that's part of what
he's planning to talk about tomorrow
when he's in Philly
um so so tomorrow look tomorrow's an
important moment for the president uh to
be in Philadelphia as you know uh the
vice president will be there with him as
well uh and will and uh he uh he um
we'll send out a note obviously this
afternoon with additional information
which as we normally do when it comes to
uh events and when he travels uh
certainly outside of DC see and and you
know what I can say now is that tomorrow
the president will will highlight
progress on water infrastructure because
there's that uh official component and
replacing lead pipes thanks to the
bipartisan infrastructure law and this
trip is a continuation of our emphasis
on implementation and this week alone we
did as you know we went to Baltimore we
went to New York City and talked about
the funding to replace a Civil War era
bridge and in New York we announced the
funding to kick start the early phase of
the Hudson tunnel project so I'll stay
there on the on the official pieces on
anything that's related to the DNC
components I would refer you to the DNC
okay thank you
um on policing Karen bass and Val
demmings were two of the lead house
advocates for the George Floyd bill they
are both no longer in the house so who
does the White House see as your best
Partners in the house on that
legislation and also are there
Republicans who the White House has
reached out to or otherwise sees as
potential Partners in the house you know
to make the numbers work so as you know
there were some Republicans in the
Senate uh that were incredibly helpful
or tried to be helpful in the last
session as it relates to the George
Floyd and just injustice and policing
act so I I would refer to you to them
and see where they are this time around
as far as it relates to the Republicans
I can tell you for this meeting I can
give you the list of attendees who will
be here and so clearly they are
certainly uh involved in this process uh
this next next state of legislation
process of Representative horseford
obviously the chair is going to be here
representative Clyburn representative
nagoos representative Jackson Lee we
have Senator Booker who played a very
big role and as you know I think you
guys all heard the vice president
mentioned yesterday in the early stages
of the bill she was involved and she'll
be in in the room as as well and we will
also have Reverend Warnock who will be
in in the meeting as well so I would I
would figure that those those folks are
certainly going to be very involved uh
in this process as well and on uh the
investigations
um can you say how many people the White
House council's Office added to prepare
for the house investigations I would
refer you to the White House council's
Office on any staffing or any specifics
on how they're moving forward with
dealing with that
okay
thank you uh two questions on foreign
policy the president just met with the
King of Jordan uh what is the White
House hopes that Jordan can play in the
escalation the violence between the
Israelis and the Palestinians no it's a
very good question as you know as you
just mentioned he met with King Abdullah
II and his Royal Highness Crown Prince
Hassan of Jordan and they had lunch
together they will reaffirm the close
enduring nature of the friendship
between the United States and Jordan and
the president will thank his majesty for
his close partnership in the role he and
Jordan play as a force of for stability
in the in the region in the Middle East
they will also discuss their vision for
the region and that highlights the
importance of cooperation and
integration as well as capitalizing on
opportunities for economic prosperity
and also stability the president will
thank his majesty for the critical role
Jordan plays in diffusing tensions in
Jerusalem and will underscore the need
to preserve the historic status quo at
the Harem al-sharif Temple Mount and
they will also address the global impact
of Russia's brutal war on Ukraine as
well also we saw today the visit of the
Israeli foreign minister to Sudan does
the White House encourage a potential
widening of the Abraham Accords to
influence countries like Sudan yeah so
we have said many times before when
there have been this type these types of
meetings that we we are always
supportive of all efforts to broaden
Israel Israel's Israelis integration
throughout the region including with
Sudan right this particular meeting so I
would refer you to the governments of
Israel and Sudan for more information
about their discussion but certainly
when it comes to the efforts of
integration in that region we support
that
thank you Korean um just a quick
follow-up on Nadia's question and then
an immigration question I'm sorry no
it's okay it's okay it's hard to it's
okay
um uh yeah just on the meeting with King
Abdullah can you speak more specifically
about how the president responded to the
king's concern that Israeli government
is not respecting the status quo at
Al-Aqsa mosque and whether the president
shared the concern of jordanians that
the new Israeli right-wing government is
escalating tensions with Palestinians so
look we've been very clear about this I
know I've gotten many questions about
the Israeli government and uh look you
know we have gotten assurances from the
Prime Minister that when it comes to uh
specifics uh policies when it comes to
um uh you know how what is decided the
policy of the government that he has
repeatedly emphasized that he will set
the policy for his government right this
is um uh this is something that he's
been very clear on
um and I do want to also add that as you
know secretary blinken was just in the
region he met with the Israeli and the
Palestinian leaders uh this is uh
clearly something that we take very
seriously of what's occurring uh in the
region you we have mentioned that the
president spoke with the Prime Minister
on Friday and Jake Sullivan a national
security adviser also spoke to his
counterparts on that day and we had the
vice president speak with the president
of Israel and so this is uh you know
this is something that we have been very
involved and very engaged and will
continue to do so really quickly on the
meeting is there any reason why it was
completely close to Christ there was no
spray and can you speak about why the
Crown Prince was also invited so look I
will say this I just laid out why we
think the uh what was was going to be in
the conversation how we saw the
conversation uh moving forward uh look
uh the private it's a private lunch
between two leaders which we've done
before it's not unusual and you know
sometimes some of the pro some of the
meetings are will have a press component
some of them won't and this one happens
to be a private meeting between the two
I would leave it to
um the king and and the um and the Crown
Prince to speak to why they came to to
the US one question on immigration can
we get your reaction detectives Texas
Governors uh appointing a special
advisor on Border matters because of
what he says as the administration's
refusal to secure the board well look
I'm not gonna look he's gonna take
whatever action he's going to take
we are we're not about political stunts
we're about dealing with a real issue
and taking action and that's what you've
seen from this President these last two
years that's what you've seen from the
president most recently announcing
border measures that's actually has made
a difference that has had an impact as
you look at the parolee program that is
what we're going to do the president
walked in on day one put forth a
immigration reform and uh you know is
asking Republicans instead of doing
political stunts to come and help him
deal with an issue but in in lieu of
that he's taken actions and we're seeing
the impact okay Peter you're about to
you're about to jump out of your seat
there you're making me nervous
[Music]
Republicans just voted to oust
congresswoman Elon Omar for the Foreign
Affairs committee overpassed
anti-semitic comments what is the White
House and the president's responses so I
have clearly you said they just it just
occurred so I haven't seen that what we
believe is congresswoman Omar is highly
respected member of Congress she has
apologized for her comments she made in
the past I think she was most recently
uh did an extensive interview about this
on Sunday I believe on CNN and has been
vocal about condemning anti-Semitism as
well as affirming our strong Alliance
and important partner partnership with
Israel look the way that we see this
it's a political stunt much like House
Republicans unjust unjust removal of
other leading Democrats from Key
committees in recent weeks and it is a
disservice to the American people if I
can ask you about the CBC meeting that's
happening this afternoon as well we
heard during The Tyree Nichols service
yesterday for the vice president who
said at the George Floyd Justice and
policing act that it was quote
non-negotiable yesterday in our exchange
you said that the White House was open
to supporting something as long as it
was done in a bipartisan fashion so is
it non-negotiable that it must be the
justice and policing act as it exists or
is the White House open to something
that's different than that if it's done
in a bipartisan yeah I think it's I I
don't think they're mutually exclusive I
think what what could be different than
the Justice I think I think what you saw
very passionately for the vice president
and I I heard that part I was I watched
her as well I what she was trying to say
is we need to get something done enough
is enough we need to get this done we
need to get a policy a police reform
that is transformational that is
actually going to bring forth real
change and the George Floyd Justice and
police enact is part of that it is uh
one step in getting to a place where it
is the law of the land that's why the
president has said many times before we
need to take legislative action we need
Congress to act so that we can see
change in States and in cities right now
as you know I just laid this out I've
laid it out yesterday laid it out just
now the president took executive action
but that's on the federal government on
the federal level and when you think
about law enforcement in the federal
level and so look
what what we heard from the vice
president was passion what we heard from
the Vice President yesterday was meeting
the moment and being there for a family
that is grieving a family that had to
watch a video of their child being uh
you know being brutalized and so she was
there comforting and being passionate
about an issue that is incredibly
important to the president and clearly
to her but others go but just to be very
clear so it is it negotiable that there
is something that achieves police reform
if it does not come in the form of the
justice and policing so what I can say
is the president
the president supported the George Floyd
uh justice and policing act last session
he supports it now again right he was
very clear when he spoke to Tyree
nichols's uh family his his mother and
his stepdad he said that he was going to
do everything that he can to encourage
and ask Congress to act that still stays
the same now he's meeting with
Congressional and black caucus to see
what can we do how do we move forward
sometimes and this is a reality we know
how Congress works right sometimes it's
going to look different and so that is
okay right if it's going to look
different but what we know what we know
that is been introduced in the past that
is clearly available to us is the George
Floyd and Justice and policing act so of
course we're going to continue to call a
call for that but you know there is
going to be conversations and we'll see
where those conversations go
Instagram uh thank you Queen a follow-up
to Peter's question given the realities
of the republican-controlled house is
the president open to a proposal on
police reform that would not include
qualified immunity just to get something
done or is that a red line for him I'm
not going to get into a conversation
that's just about to happen in a couple
of hours and where we're going to
potentially and that's going to be a
beginning probably of multiple
conversations I'm not going to sit here
and say what's a red line or stand here
clearly and say what's a red line and
what we won't or won't do I want to be
very careful there but what I'm saying
is the president is committed is
committed to uh you know to working with
Congress for Congress to act so it can
become the land of the law of the land
and we don't have to continue to see
communities especially as we know
disproportionately sadly brown and black
communities across the country being
affected by this issue again that's why
the president took executive action when
but when uh to be very Frank when
Republicans refused to to act uh the
last session and I believe you said
yesterday that you would check with NSC
on the question of whether athletes from
Russia and Belarus should be allowed to
compete at the Olympic Games in Paris
this is of course drawing a lot of
attention at this time do you have any
ideas on the administration I do I
checked in with NSC and I have
a robust update for you
so as you know the United States has
rallied the world to support the people
of Ukraine as I just laid out moments
ago and we have worked to hold Russia
accountable for the brutal and barbaric
War their forces are waging against
Ukraine so as part of those efforts the
United States has supported suspending
Russia and Belarus broke belarus's sport
National governing bodies from
International Sports Federation removing
individuals closely aligned to the
Russian and Belarusian States including
government officials from positions of
influence and international sport
federations such as boards and
organizing committees encouraging
National and International Sports organ
organizations to suspend and
broadcasting of sports competition in
into Russia and Belarus in cases where
Sports organizations and event
organizers such as the international
Olympic committees a committee choose to
permit athletes from Russia and Belarus
to participate in supporting events it
should be absolutely clear that they are
not representing the Russian or
Belarusian States and so that's the
stance that we are providing and the use
of official state Russian belarusians
Flags emblems and athems should be
prohibited as well okay and then I'll
come to the back okay thank you uh just
back on budget talks uh yesterday
McCarthy suggested that what he would
like to see ultimately if there can be
an agreement is a two-year budget
framework what's the president's
thinking on that uh what I will say is
the president's going to put forth his
Budget on March 9th he's going to be
very clear with the American people he's
going to lay out what he believes of his
fiscal responsibilities or priorities
are for the American people and we asked
the speaker to do the same and until we
see that it's hard to talk about
timeline it's hard to talk about
specifics because we need to actually
see on paper what they're going to move
forward with on that point um you know
almost 50 years ago as a Senator Joe
Biden voted for a framework or timeline
has the president proposing a budget
first and then Congress disposing of
that budget why is it the argument here
that the Republicans should put forward
their budget first isn't isn't it
actually that's not what we said we're
going to put out our budget on March 9th
and we're asking Republicans to do the
same because here's the thing Steve what
we keep hearing from Republicans is that
they want to cut Social Security right
which is something that tax payers pay
into and uh we believe that the
president the president has said he's
going to continue to fight for Social
Security we keep hearing that they want
to cut Medicare which is also a problem
because it's going to hurt taxpayers who
pay into that we're talking about
seniors we're talking about veterans and
so we oppose that we are against that
but that's what they keep saying and
many of you all have reported but we
haven't but what where's the plan like
what is it that they're going to lay out
to show us exactly not just to us but to
the American people now I want to be
very clear the conversation that the
president and the speaker had yesterday
was productive we appreciated the time
that the speaker gave to the to the
president to have a conversation and our
teams again have been in touch and we'll
see where we go from there the law says
that the president's budget to do the
first Monday in February Joe Biden is
not the first president to be late but
he is going to be late and it's now five
weeks from today that you've said that
the budget will come out can you explain
why it is it is delayed I think you were
asked this last week and there was a
suggestion that it might have something
to do with the Omnibus but is there is
that the reason is there yeah and I
basically said the Omnibus happened so
late uh in the as you know in the last
session which caused us to you know be a
little bit later with um with the
president's budget so that did there's
definitely a correlation there but
here's the thing the president has made
a promise that he's going to have his
Budget on March 9th that's what we're
going to do that's what he's going to to
show to the American people and we want
to see what the what the house
Republicans are going to put forward
okay I'll go to the back good Garrett
thanks Maureen Republicans who have
expressed resistance to passing the
George Floyd Bill have argued that
there's no law that would have prevented
the deadly beating of Tyree nickels uh
does the White House agree with that so
look I'll say this
um when it comes to
um
this issue the police police reform and
dealing with an issue that's certainly
affecting many communities the brown and
black communities specifically and
asking would would the George Floyd
Injustice and policing act have changed
anything we believe would it would have
strengthened accountability measures
which we think is important for federal
officers at the state and local level we
think that's important it would give the
Department of Justice expanded powers to
go after departments that have patterns
of or practices of excessive force bias
policing and other unconstitutional
practices it would require the
Department of Justice to establish
accredation standards for law
enforcement agencies it would require
officers to complete training on racial
profiling implicit bias and the duty to
intervene when another officer uses
excessive force the president repeatedly
calls for Congress to pass the George
Floyd act that even leading law on law
enforcement organizations supported the
reform as well and when they could not
take action or would not act the
president acted and put forth an
executive action and as I stated before
that is that executive action was
supported by families who have been
affected who lost loved ones to to
police police brutality and it was
supported even by law enforcement it was
supported by civil rights civil rights
organizations as well look uh you know
this is the first step I was explaining
that to Peter George Floyd and Justice
policing act while yes it will it will
start the process and hopefully dealing
with a real systemic issue a systemic
problem it is also one of the ways that
we can start dealing with that
well the question um an activists have
identified the issue of traffic stops as
a potential area of policy Focus that do
you does the White House see that as a
potential area where there can be
bipartisan uh support or even through
executive order again I don't want to
get into uh specific on getting
bipartisan support for any piece of
provision or policy that would be in the
legislation I'm going to allow the
president to have his conversation with
the Congressional Black Caucus see how
that goes and uh you know continue to
talk to Congress about acting and and
making sure that we deal with this issue
go ahead James in the back green thank
you I have two questions one about the
document's case and one about the Tyree
Nichols funeral on the documents case
one of the features of the early public
Narrative of this episode that has kind
of already taken root is the reporting
to the effect that statements from this
Podium at different points later proved
to be inaccurate and without expecting
you to delve into the details because we
all know that you cannot from the podium
I nonetheless wonder if you could simply
assure us that you challenge that
element in this narrative that you are
satisfied personally with the accuracy
of all of the information that the chief
dispense for this book so James look
I'll say at this Podium I will always
follow the the guidance of the White
House Council Office when it comes to
ongoing investigations we've been very
uh you know we've been very clear about
just ongoing investigations that is led
by the Department of Justice making sure
that they have their independence we
this is something that the president has
talked about through the campaign and
through the last two years I have been
consistent about that when I have made
statements from this Podium on this
investigation it was at the guidance of
the council's office and consistent with
what they have said and wanted to
communicate at the time right and I have
said this the White House council's
office has said this uh one of the
reasons we try not to comment on this is
because it's changing right it is
currently it is currently under
investigation and when you have a legal
matter as you know I know you understand
this things change and things move very
very quickly and so I've continued to
provide the information that I have had
at the time and I will continue to do
that
Tyree Nichols funeral
imposing this question
with no aspersions Castle I think all
observers thought was a very eloquent
eulogy delivered by the Vice President I
think it the event calls into question
how the Bible White House goes about
deciding which atrocities which
tragedies
Merit high level attention from the
presidential vice president so in
addition to the Nichols Funeral For
example we saw that the president called
the parents of Damar Hamlin injured NFL
player I checked the White House website
just before coming into the breathing
room today and I see no indication that
the chief executive has at any time
reached out to the family of Justin
McIntyre who was the police chief in
Brackenridge Pennsylvania who was shot
to death in the line of duty a father of
four why not
so I'll say this if you look at this
president who has been a Senator for 36
years who has been a vice president for
eight years and who has been clearly uh
you know finished up his is finishing up
his uh two years uh tenure and a
four-year uh presidency thus far
um he
you know if you know of Joe by Joe Biden
you know that he feels the pain of many
families who have lost loved ones
because he knows what that means you've
named one family in particular I
understand why you're naming that family
in particular but there's been many
families that he has called to offer up
um
you know to offer up his condolences and
offer up his help and assistance in any
way we do not read out all of those uh
all of those conversations but if you
know Joe Biden and if you've been around
Joe Biden you know that this is
something that the president does in a
way that many politicians at least that
I have worked for are not won't can't do
are not capable of of doing and the
president will always be committed and
always be open to talking to families
who are hurting who are going through a
tough time especially of a lost loved
one and I think the two that you just
named we're just very public they were
two incredibly public situations that
that where you know uh where um where
the president was able to reach out in a
way that that people knew about right
that people were able to see how the
president uses what change does so well
his understanding his compassion for
others and so I would not again you
named one family the president has been
uh clearly in the world of politics for
a long time and he has had many many
conversations with families who have
lost lost ones I'm going to continue to
go around
I have a question about environment
scenes and treatments are accessible and
not too expensive
insurance
after they have emergency ends and he
said quote more details to follow does
that mean there's a new program in the
works what will be announced in the
coming days in the coming weeks will
require more funding so a good question
don't have anything to share with you at
this time what I can commit to you and
what we are trying to do is we're we're
planning for a smooth transition when it
comes to the public health
and a smooth transition for our
emergency policies in May that is our
commitment that's always been our
commitment from this Administration it
does not mean we're done fighting covet
right as as Dr Jaws laying out how we're
going to move forward we are working and
coordinating around the clock with
hospitals with local public health
departments and leaders and they are in
they are an integral part to the process
of a smooth transition and you know that
said because of the work that we've done
to fight kovid from day one from the
moment that the president walked into
this Administration we are in a better
place than when we were when we first
started and that is because of the work
that this Administration has done and
and so we'll continue to do that it's
still we're still fighting covet as I
just laid out and we'll have more uh to
share but just wanted to be very clear
that it is uh it is a transition and
it's going to take some time and we'll
have the appropriate conversations and
then on entitlements what's the
president's plan for avoiding automatic
benefit cuts to Social Security and
Medicare if not
so look we're going to we're going to
continue to ask not going to get into
hypotheticals about what what actions
could be done down the road what we're
going to ask the speaker as we have in
our letter as we have stated many times
before we want to see what their plan is
we've heard from the house Republican
Congress but we want to get a sense of
are you is this what you all are going
to do are you going to cut Medicare are
you going to cut Social Security and
keep that hostage for their you know to
to to to
um to hold it so that they don't do
their constitutional Duty which is lift
the debt ceiling and so let's see let's
see uh what the house Republican
conference is going to do with the house
is going to do more broadly Republicans
in particular but look again we the
president and the speaker had a very
productive conversation and we're
looking to continue to have uh have
those talks okay
oh thank you whoever wants him first
Karine uh Council for Hunter Biden has
written the National Security division
of the justice department I know you
like to keep that agency very arms
length but is it arm's life when the
president's son writes seeking rights
doj seeking an investigation I mean look
I'm going to be pretty consistent as I
have been uh from this Podium when it
relates to that uh that particular
question that you you're asking me we
have been for the last two years and I
will say to you that that is something
for uh Hunter Biden's uh personal
representative their representative to
speak to I'm just not going to speak to
it from here the White House knew about
before it happened again I would um
as far as that piece I would refer you
to the White House Council Office and
again I don't have anything to add this
is something for his personal
representatives to speak to uh and uh as
it relates to the agencies as you were
asking me look uh this is a president
and I said this before that believes in
the independence of the Department of
Justice or any any enforcement
investigations and he's been very clear
about that he believes that it should
not be politicized as he has said for
the past a couple of years starting in
the campaign and he believes that uh
that any any any
investigation should be independent so
again I would refer you to the specific
agencies that's involved here I'm just
not going to comment beyond that sounded
like you had something to say on the
other one yes but um important how they
organize that investigation with the
justices so look I'm not going to I'm
not going to speak to the actions that
the Supreme Court as it relates to the
investigation of the Dobbs decision what
I will say and reiterate what the
president said the day that uh that the
Dobbs decision occurred right which is
back in June uh which is it was a it was
a constitutional right for 50 years
almost 50 years and it was taken away
and uh women's rights that we're talking
about women's rights we're talking about
a woman's right to choose and we think
that that action was wrong and not just
us if you look at the midterms and and
what the American people said they
believe that we should be continuing to
fight for Americans rights and so that's
what we're going to continue to do you
heard from
Jen Klein who runs our gender policy
Council she has done a phenomenal job
speaking to groups trying to figure out
ways that we can continue to protect a
woman's rights to choose and also she
mentioned the vice president as well and
the president has spoken to this many
many times before and so I'll leave it
there I'm not going to speak to any
legal actions or that were or
investigations that were taken by the
Supreme Court okay I I promised him the
last I promised him a question okay it's
just a just a logistical question for
the State of the Union day should we
anticipate that the president will be
offering a preview of his remarks and
thinking to the network television
anchors at lunch or as it's been the
tradition on on the State of the Union
day we will have more to share as we get
closer to the date I don't have anything
at this time thanks everybody all right
see you guys in Friday